hey guys I was invited out to Houston
Texas yesterday by the make-a-wish
Foundation to meet Danelle a Danelle has
leukemia a ll and has a bone marrow
transplant scheduled for this Thursday
so I hope you'll all join me in wishing
her the best of luck in her surgery and
oddly enough her wish was to meet me and
that is a huge honor and we hung out we
played video games and we even made a
short video about us playing video games
and joking around so I hope you'll enjoy
this video it was a lot of fun to make
we had a lot of fun making it making it
was a great fun fun had been had when we
were making it so enjoy watching us make
this video where we had fun yo what's up
my flippity as you know how I introduce
all my videos I'm here I'm I'm recording
a video here I'm doing a little baby
witnesses my flip ADIZ will not like
this Yoma flippity is like i don't know
what root digs happening here but some
manners be lacking
flapjacks and pancakes I didn't get you
any pressure how does that make you feel
I probably don't I'm only here because
I'm obligated to they've been asking me
to name them for a long time it's been
like the mark applies to the markiplier
heroes
I like the flippity pivot ease what do
you think of the flippity pivot ease no
oh okay
well Danelle has spoken by the way I'm
here for the make-a-wish Foundation I
didn't just creep up on someone playing
video games cuz I don't do that was cups
empty welcome to Danelle but welcome to
the let's play Danelle that's that's
demel say hi hi
that's Danelle and she's playing some
dragon ball bowl game I don't know I've
never heard of it
so whoo look at that hello baby
hello how's it going hello
look at me
hello what's going on how's it going
over here
what's happening you okay day by day day
day day - Dodie day no - no David oh no
a hundred I have a hundred billion a
hundred billion billion yeah take that
PewDiePie
terrible celebs Liberty vivid ease she's
gonna say something nicer this time you
said you were gonna say something
okay flibberty pivot ease we're back
with more Dragon Ball battle of Z uh
smells getting better not very good but
still getting better at what she was
doing so uh we got our own cheering
session he's really really really happy
about how she's doing
yeah I know beat him up beat him up yeah
beat up all those bad guys so any any
insightful commentary about those who
want to play this game and
and be good at games in general practice
you hear her to hear first flippity
pities janelle tells you to practice so
it becomes a practice makes perfect
right day yeah flippity pivot ease him
back I just stomped an L here I in
dragon ball I showed her the ropes
I showed her how it's really done when
you're a professional gamer like me yeah
she was crying real bad so this day just
like sympathy crying you should have
seen it was awesome I was laughing so
hard they were just crying like big
babies tears going down their face oh
man I've never felt happier in my life
about it but anyway so we're about to
play some Mario Kart here and I'm gonna
destroy her again I'm a crusher hopes
and dreams it's gonna be the greatest
feeling that I've ever had in my life so
what do you think what do you think what
do you think of that thank you
my take all you subscribers if she could
say right maybe she would earn them oh
good you are yo-yo we'll sell my
flippity pivot ease I just stomped
Danella in Mario Kart I've never even
played motion controls before but will
you lose at the top I'm Bowser by the
way I'm out I'm Bella so
look at that the top like it's crazy how
good I am at games and anyway I mean
either any words to say about your
shameful defeat oh she doesn't watch the
wish anymore yo yo yo yo yo yo my
flippidy booties um again I have one a
claim victory
it feels great knowing that I have
dominated everything that I've done up
to this point I am so unbelievably good
at games that I have also could you put
up the score yeah there it is see
another another proper proper
first-place victory for the March EMU
who is great
I just a great great general any other
words of encouragement you have for me I
don't have any curry I don't need it
because my heart very good Liberty pivot
ease I have terrible terrible news to
tell you I mean it's it's it's probably
the worst thing that's ever happened in
my life I got second place at the end
not to develop the trick up you bak Chi
Chi's driftwood 11 foot I uh
I suffered a horrible cataclysmic
tragedy at the end I was blue shelled
that red shelled that all did I hit a
banana or something that was thrown
midair from across the map this is the
only reason why I lost cuz all these
things came together at once and so
obviously this is sad news for everyone
else you know we black magic what do you
think about that horrible thing that
happened to me I'm glad I hit you
well
all right then flippity pivot ease I did
it I I clinched it I did so good I'm so
proud of me and I'm so proud of you guys
for believing in me and what I've done
and even the trophies what see this is
what makes it all worth it this is why
I'm so happy to be here with the
make-a-wish Foundation you know this
makes me feel so good being the victor
the winner the ultimate champion of
everything even though in the last round
fate decided that it would be cruel to
me and give me second place I mean you
know how bad second place feels now that
you got second place in Laughlin right
right really second place isn't it but
I'm in first place right I'm sorry I'm
not this mean right right guys rightful
ibbety-bibbety zone others mean
okay guys I know I've been joking around
a lot I just wanted to take a moment to
say hi officially to Jenelle here and
let you guys know that I am here for the
make-a-wish Foundation for some reason
this was Jenelle's wish to have me come
down here so I'm very much honored if
you want to take a moment to talk about
your condition and why like you invited
me out here to talk and play I have
cancer
leukemia most
yeah so she's got a bone marrow
transplant coming up soon so we all wish
her the very best of luck I just wanted
to say I'm absolutely honored they chose
me to be your make-a-wish foundation
person so I just want to say thank you
so much I don't have a lot of time here
I wish I had more time but it's been a
very it's so good are you sure because I
was insulting you a lot of money but
that that's how you know that I'm
friendly with so that's because if you
look at all the friends that I have I
treat them the exact same way so don't
worry about so I just want to say thank
you so much for inviting me out here and
is there anything you want to say to
anyone out there always one specific
girl was a fan of you Jennifer I am in
Mike replied
yay hi Jennifer okay bye Jennifer
boy